[Musica]
[Applauso]
improvvisamente È tutto sostenibile
giornali televisioni etichette Social
non si parla d'altro è tutto sostenibile
Ma è davvero
così dobbiamo far CEA questa
domanda dobbiamo pensare di ridare a
questa parola il suo giusto significato
per fare le corrette scelte nella nostra
vita Ecco io 15 anni fa mi sono
avvicinata a questa materia che poi è
diventata la mia passione e il mio
lavoro e ho capito in poco tempo che
possiamo agire per
trasformare il modello di produzione
consumo che abbiamo
costruito Riducendo il suo impatto verso
l'uomo e verso
l'ambiente possiamo
farlo e possiamo far anche in unore come
quello della moda in cui qualcuno pensa
che non sia proprio
possibile La moda è un'a Compa che fa
uso di tantissime
risorse acqua energia chimica persone è
estremamente frammentata nel suo modello
produttivo produciamo in tutto il mondo
in un mondo in cui i paesi hanno
caratteristiche diverse di sviluppo
economico ambientale e sociale e in cui
le normative sono estremamente
diverse Ma voi lo sapevate e prima ce
l'ha
anticipato che per produrre una t-shirt
occorrono 2800 l di acqua che per per un
paio di jeans 3800 l di acqua
utilizziamo all'interno del
settore emettiamo circa il 10% delle
emissione di gas serra a livello
globale sapete il gas serra sono quelli
a cui impu tiamo il famoso cambiamento
climatico solo il 3% dei nostri abiti
viene
riciclato e utilizziamo
3500 sostanze chimiche per tingere
stampare conciare rifinire e la scienza
da diversi anni ci ha detto che di
queste sostanze 750 sono cve per la
salute dell'uomo e circa 400 per
l'ambiente Quindi queste sostanze che ci
servono per la performance dei nostri
prodotti per renderli migliori sono
quelle sostanze che poi fanno male alla
nostra salute e alterano i sistemi gli
ecosistemi soprattutto a Valle delle
fabbriche di
produzione ora
Questo diciamo noi abbiamo anche una
responsabilità verso quei paesi in cui
mandiamo tutta quella Perdonatemi
spazzatura pensate a Cile e gana in cui
i nostri abiti vanno a finire dopo che
li abbiamo usati qualche
volta
ecco per 50 anni oltre 50 anni abbiamo
prodotto secondo questo modello il
modello in cui la massima utilizzazione
delle risorse la massima contrazione dei
costi è stato quello che ha spinto la
produzione e il consumo e oggi però
abbiamo una grande opportunità e sono
qui anche per
condividerla con voi sono qui per darvi
una buona notizia la notizia è che
possiamo fare diversamente il sistema si
può assolutamente modificare il il
meccanismo di produzione che per 50 anni
abbiamo utilizzato Oggi possiamo
trasformarlo abbiamo processi abbiamo
materiali
abbiamo impianti che utilizzano meno
acqua meno energia e meno sostanze
chimiche tossiche e nocive e li abbiamo
è già tutto dimostrato si tratta di
volerlo si tratta di mettere in atto
un'innovazione di prodotto e di processo
investendo per cambiare il nostro
modello di produzione e
consumo si tratta di innovare
costantemente
prodotti processi e soprattutto di
attuare una grande rivoluzione Io credo
che la più importante innovazione che
noi tutti siamo chiamati a fare è quella
della rivoluzione culturale Ognuno di
noi ha la possibilità di mettere in atto
scelte azioni quotidiane all'interno del
mondo del lavoro e anche fuori e è la
somma di queste azioni di quelle azioni
attraverso le quali decidiamo come
Progettare un prodotto come produrlo
come distribuirlo e come
acquistarlo Quindi questa rivoluzione la
facciamo tutti insieme ma Chi è che ha
la più grande
responsabilità chi fa questa rivoluzione
brand e consumatore sono coloro che
hanno la più grande responsabilità Il
Brand Perché può decidere di Convertire
le intere sue collezioni in collezioni
sostenibili prodotte da filiere
responsabili il consumatore Perché può
decidere di destinare le sue risorse a
prodotti che sono soltanto in grado di
fornire attributi positivi di
sostenibilità e basandosi su dati perché
oggi abbiamo le metodologie per misurare
l'impatto ridurlo e comunicarlo Quindi
quando andiamo ad acquistare possiamo
informarci facciamo diventare di moda la
corsa all'acquisto
consapevole proviamo a a riassumere
quali sono quindi gli elementi della
moda sostenibile quindi a volte lo
sentiamo dire in maniera tanto diffusa
ma ci sono quattro elementi
fondamentali il primo deve avere
materiali derivanti da pratiche
industriali virtuose materiali che usano
meno acqua meno energia che salvano
quelle risorse che abbiamo visto prima
due deve essere caratterizzata da
prodotti che allungano il vita il ciclo
di vita e quindi che vengono utilizzati
riutilizzati che stanno nel mio
guardaroba e poi nel guardaroba di
qualcun altro e che
vengono realizzati attraverso pratiche
industriali che ne assicurano la
durabilità Tre tre sono realizzati
attraverso fabbriche sicure attraverso
fabbriche che assicurano al dipendente
il benessere e che risparmiano
attraverso i loro processi acqua energia
ed emissione in
atmosfera quattro Non ultimo se abbiamo
fatto tutto quello che abbiamo visto
fino a qui ma non lo abbiamo dotato di
un sistema di raccolta dati e di
tracciabilità non potremo saperlo e
quindi come scegliamo Ecco le Nor che
stanno arrivando Ci aiuteranno anche a
fare questo Digital product Passport è
il passaporto digitale attraverso il
quale potremo vedere tutte queste
informazioni dove è stato prodotto come
è stato prodotto chi lo ha prodotto
quale impatto mi ha generato e intanto
che arriva Questo passaporto iniziamo a
farle queste domande iniziamo ad
aumentare le fonti di informazioni che
ci permettono di fare acquisti
consapevoli
Il Brand in tutto questo può fare
assolutamente la differenza può
convertire intere collezioni a questo
tipo di
produzione Permettetemi di esprimere un
desiderio cosa vorrei che si acceler
asse al massimo Vorrei tanti più Brand
che aderissero a questa politica con
designer che sviluppano prodotti
ecosostenibili Vorrei tante più
fabbriche che investono insieme al brand
in partnership per per poter ridurre i
litri di acqua le tonnellate di
emissione in atmosfera e la chimica
tossica e nociva e vorrei tanti più
consumatori che si chiedono ma mi serve
davvero dove è stato prodotto chi lo ha
prodotto questo Brand mi
rappresenta sarà l'insieme di tutte
queste domande quello che salverà i
litri di acqua e le tonnellate di
emissione in atmosfera e poi per
ultimo proverei anche a sfidare gli
influencer e coloro che si occupano di
messaggi al mercato perché attraverso la
moda abbiamo creato sempre una nuova
cultura è la moda che ha creato cultura
e quindi perché no perché non lanciare
questi messaggi ora Io so bene che da
soli non si può cambiare il mondo ma
proviamo a moltiplicare tutte queste
piccole cose che ci siamo detti in
questi 10 minuti insieme moltiplichiamo
per 10 per 100 per un milione e anche
per un miliardo Ecco cosa accade
Salviamo acqua energia emissioni il
mondo si ripulisce dice un proverbio
africano quando le formiche si mettono
insieme possono spostare un elefante
Grazie